the thing I remember the most is one
doing we did several experiments with
cell lines with blood cells taken from
ex vivo we call it you take the blood
cells out and you culture them in a dish
and you work with them we had done four
different experiments in vitro to in
vivo to in vitro and I'd analyzed that
data and I looked in the literature and
looked at genes that change and when
people are rejecting organs and I've
been looking at all these tests
molecules that we had and there was this
convergence that there were a couple of
genes that we saw in all of our models
that changed and when I looked in the
literature they were changing in the
opposite direction so when you were
transplant in the transplant scenario
their expression level was going up and
in our models without our test drugs the
expression level was going down that was
a very exciting moment because I thought
this is really cool I think I have
something I got on the phone and I
called call my colleague over in the
therapeutic area I think I have
something I've got something this looks
very promising this looks really good we
gotta test it and I think that was a
very exciting moment
you